avec nous ce matin alexandre touzet et
vice président délégué lr à la
prévention de la délinquance à la
sécurité du conseil départemental de
l'essonne alexandre touzet bonjour
bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation dans la matinale de rtl
france alors cette fameuse tribune des
généraux n'en finit plus de faire parler
d'elle le chef d'état major des armées a
donc annoncé des sanctions contre 18
militaires d'actifs dont quatre généraux
signataires de cette tribune est ce que
c'est une décision qui vous semble
logique mais écoutez effectivement quand
on est dans l'armée dans l'actif de
l'armée en retraite si on doit pas
prendre des positions politiques donc la
réponse de l'armée à ses 18 militaires
qui sont actifs est tout à fait normal
il en est autrement bien sûr pourquoi
les militaires qui sont à la retraite et
qui ont eu un droit d'expression
elle vous assure que vous cette tribune
je pense qu'elle je distinguerai le fond
et la forme
la forme est un petit peu excessive il y
avait aussi une ambiguïté je pense qui
n'est pas raisonnable
l'ambiguïté apport sur le fait que le
recours à l'armée pour être au tour
décidé par l'armée et non pas à venir du
pouvoir civil
alors je me doute que dans la tête et
dans l'esprit de ses généraux bien sûr
il faisait référence à un gouvernement
qu'ils feraient appel aux militaires
pour rétablir la paix civile mais
l'ambiguïté est quand même condamnable
je pense notamment à ce niveau de gamme
après la réaction du gouvernement elle
me semble aussi approprié parce que
c'est un peu comme la devise chinoise
ces records le sage montre la lune
l'idiot regarde le doigt
il ya des vrais des rita problèmes de
sécurité et je pense que au lieu de
faire monter un quarteron de ministre
pour dire ô combien c'est mal et ô
combien
c'est une pensée désastreux je pense
qu'il fallu résoudre les problèmes alors
justement ces problèmes de sécurité il y
en a eu encore hier à bagnolet un
policier a été transporté à l'hôpital
après une violente agression en service
on a aussi vu sur les réseaux sociaux
ces images de rodéo à bordeaux ou encore
à lyon beaucoup uns dénoncent cette
montée de la violence
ces incivilités quotidiennes vous le
voyez en voit à l'image ces rodéos vous
qui vous vous étudier ces questions de
sécurité est ce que c'est le cas aussi
pour vous dans l'essonne est ce que vous
constatez une montée de la délinquance
et dernières années et si vous vous
l'expliquez comment
oui on constate une montée de la
délinquance
je voudrais aussi ne pas caricaturer
parce que dans les quartiers dont on
parle il ya aussi une partie de la
jeunesse une partie importante de la
jeunesse qui a envie des tickets car
envie de travailler qui a envie
d'innover mais effectivement il ya des
jeunes qui sont rupture la république à
des jeunes qui trouvent dans des fan de
gueulante au rythme de stupéfiants et
donc effectivement le constat est on
voit bien dans les sondages les français
le temps sur le stade l'ultra violence
sur le constat d'une commandite d'une
situation qui échappe au pouvoir
politique ce constat là il largement
partagée par parler français alors
l'actualité c'est aussi le projet de loi
antiterroriste a présenté hier par éric
dupond nos rites et et eric
dupond-moretti pardon parmi ces mesures
un suivi des détenus radicaliser
regarder ces mesures c'est d'abord des
mesures judiciaires de réinsertion
sociale antiterroriste destinée à
renforcer le suivi des personnes
condamnées
qui est concerné par cela qui sera
concerné par cette mesure
ce sont les condamnés pour des faits de
terrorisme à cinq ans d'emprisonnement
et plus et où en cas de récidive à trois
ans d'emprisonnement et plus qui
prononce cette mesure c'est le tribunal
d'application des peines après un débat
contradictoire alors des mesures de
réinsertion sociale
antiterroriste vous en pensez quoi et
côté d'or dans ce texte il ya des bonnes
mesures et des mesures sur le l'aspect
technique je pense aux algorithmes je
pense au suivi des grl je pense aux
programmations satellitaire on se donne
des moyens techniques pour davantage
combattent la lutte contre le terrorisme
islamique
aussi ai je dois le dire on a évité par
rapport à l'ampleur du problème
on n'aborde pas la question des
rétentions administratives le suivi des
personnes condamnées ce sur une période
extrêmement courte deux ans on en voit
bien que ça nécessite en fait des outils
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus fort et puis
on oublie certains sujets moi je pense
par exemple la reconnaissance faciale
des fichiers est ce pour quoi on
mettrait pas en place des outils qui
nous permettrait à la porte et
commissariats des écoles des gros lieu
de rassemblement sportif par exemple la
reconnaissance faciale des fichiers est
ce pour assurer la sécurité de nos
compatriotes
mais je pense aussi au crible des
fonctionnaires on a eu un attentat au
coeur de la préfecture de police de
paris pourquoi pas systématiquement
crible et les fonctionnaires les trois
fonctions publiques hospitalière
collectivités locales et état pourra
éviter ce qui a bien été mis en avant
par les ministres lors de l'exposition
de la proposition de loi afin d'exposer
de la présentation sa proposition de loi
pardon ce risque endogène sûr que le
risque maintenant il intérêt à
l'intérieur du pays et c'est ça qu'il
faut véritablement attaquer mais c'est
cette idée d'accompagner ces détenus
radicaliser avec des avec des
assistantes sociales les faire
travailler pour vous ça peut être une
mesure efficace
écoutez il ya tout un aspect à
déconstruire
je pense qu'il faut qu'à un moment on
puisse essayer de leur donner les
effectivement une perspective de sortie
de réinsertion mais sans trop de naïveté
quand même et je crois que les durées
qui sont
envisagées notamment de cette durée
d'observation après l'exécution de la
peine de deux ans me semble être une
durée un peu un peu d'air et je crois
qu'il faut un petit peu revisité un peu
le carcan constituent certaines règles
en france pour pouvoir les s'attaquer
vrai véritablement sur le faux problème
alors sur le fond cette semaine valérie
pécresse a reconnu elle un lien entre
terrorisme et l'immigration et regardez
ce qu'en pense sur le sujet le ministre
de l'intérieur il peut y avoir un lien
entre des attentats terroristes et
l'immigration
cela nous a été montré à nice à
rambouillet mais ce lien n'est pas
automatique sur 100% des attentats qu'il
ya eu ces cinq dernières années les
trois quarts ont été commis par des gens
qui ont la nationalité française depuis
le 29 septembre dernier
vingt mille titres de séjour ont été
retirés pour des actes de délinquance
nous jugeons les étrangers en france
pour ce qu'ils font pas pour ce qu'ils
sont alors il ne faut pas confondre la
politique de lutte contre le terrorisme
est la politique migratoire c'est ce
qu'a également martelé hier jean castex
vous est ce que vous le faites ce lien
par l'écouté si on prend les
statistiques ici on prend effectivement
la part globalement la part de la
population étrangère par rapport à la
part de la population française on peut
retourner le ce texte les statistiques
avancées par le ministre de l'intérieur
en disant que en valeur absolue mais en
pourcentage
on a effectivement plus de faits commis
par des personnes étrangères sur le
territoire que sur des personnes avec
une réalité française mais au delà de ce
problème moi je crois ce qu'il faut
viser c'est que sur notre territoire on
a une partie de la jeunesse qui a des
papiers d'identité qui en train de
dériver vers des thèses on ne le voit
qu'il ya la laïcité et est fortement
contestée on a une pratique religieuse
de plus en plus rigoristes et moi ce qui
m'inquiète je le dis franchement c'est
la situation dans quatre cinq ans avec
une partie de la jeunesse qui peut
dériver est il véritablement bien sûr il
faut traiter le
le sujet de l'immigration sérieusement
c'est pas acceptable à rambouillet on a
vu que quelqu'un reste 10 en situation
irrégulière en france c'est bien entendu
inacceptable et je pense que ça pose un
véritable problème aux autorités en
termes de réponse d'efficacité la
réponse mais on doit aussi prévenir
l'avenir et il pensait l'avenir et je
pense qu'il faut faire extrêmement
attention attention on voit que il ya
des jeunes qui se détache de la
république se détachent des valeurs
républicaines il faut être extrêmement
attentif à ce terreau et ramener ces
jeunes maîtres de l'éducation m des
valeurs il faut pas qu'on ait ce
séparatisme que l'on commence pendant ce
qui s'installe profondément en france
c'est quoi il il faut il faut repenser
l'école aujourd'hui pour vous très
clairement parce que ce qu'on voit et
j'aurais revenir quelques années en
arrière ceux qui ont fait le jihad c'est
des jeunes qui est en france qui sont
passés par les écoles primaires par le
collège parfois par le lycée qui ont
fréquenté l'établissement culturel qui
aurait fréquenté nos établissements
sportifs et en fait ça ne l'a pas
empêché de partir faire le jack donc ça
doit être pour tous les acteurs de la
vie publique
les tableaux remise en cause ce sont des
jeunes français qui dérive et je pense
qu'il faut vraiment porté une attention
très forte
asta le mali il est là il est chez nous
et je ne je pense qu'il faut faire
attention oui alors demain une prise de
parole attendue celle d' emmanuel macron
pour annoncer le calendrier du
desserrement des contraintes sanitaires
il ne fera dans la presse régionale est
ce que c'est le bon moment qu'est ce que
vous attendez de la part du chef de
l'état comme stratégie quand les côtés
je pense oui il faut évoluer parce que
on voit bien qu'au bout d'un certain
temps en fait les règles ont du mal à
être accepté ont du mal à être
[Musique]
réellement mises en oeuvre
vois bien une grosse partie de la
population qui en a marre et et au bout
d'un certain temps en fait les règles
sont tellement contourner qu'elles sont
[Musique]
c'est à dire presque dangereuse on voit
bien que l'interdiction en fait par
exemple les fréquenter afin de mettre un
diction d'aller au restaurant ou au café
donne des rassemblements dans des
studios et 3 donne lieu à des fêtes
clandestines et donc effectivement pour
un peu de soupape pour essayer de
réfléchir et tout l'enjeu maintenant ça
va être de mettre en place des
protocoles qui nous permet d'éviter la
contamination et protocole contraignant
mais qui nous permettent de revenir vers
au moins un petit peu alhaji de souffler
et de donner aussi un peu d'oxygène à
des gens qui sont enfermés je pense
depuis le moment je pense notamment aux
étudiants qui sont moins l'université
qui n'ont pu lui sociale il faut leur
donner un peu de souffle aussi dans pour
ça les séquelles extrêmement compliqué
donc oui tenait un peu de souffle d avec
les protocoles très encadrée pour que ce
retour à la vie ne dégénère pas un
énième au film en quelques mois alors il
ya la question derrière bien évidemment
de la vaccination
on en parle quotidiennement beaucoup
demandent à ce que cette vaccination
elle soit étendu à toute la population
la réponse du gouvernement pour le
moment c'est non les personnes
prioritaires d'abord qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez vous il faut ouvrir la
vaccination à tous le monde aujourd'hui
je pense que le modèle israélien était
pas mauvais c'est à dire que en israël
il y avait des cases dash autoritaire
bella phone la journée les gens
recevaient aurait par texto de
l'administration un message en disant
vous pouvez vous présenter et en fait
c'est un système qui permettait qu'il y
ait zéro gâchis aujourd'hui c'est tout à
fait inacceptable qu'on ait des créneaux
qui soit pas rempli par exemple c'est le
cas dans l'essonne vous le constatez ou
pas que les français bout de cette
vaccination
non non nous on a plutôt on a plutôt des
centres de vaccination qui tombe bien on
était plutôt serein jusqu'ici un manque
de doses voilà après c'est vrai pourquoi
pas ça se passe bien dans nos centres en
tout cas dans les deux centres de
proximité qui couvre les villes d'europe
qu'un territoire à jour et elle est
réussie c'est que en fait ces centres
sont venus par des médecins
ils sont en lien avec les villes qui en
fait appel les personnes âgées ou un
fait tout un travail pour les mettre en
confiance pour organiser le transport
etc
et donc ces petits centres qui sont
tenues à la fois par le conseil
départemental par le personnel des
mairies ou les personnes qui se font
vacciner sont accompagnés par nos
centres communaux d'action sociale ces
centres lave fonctionne bien parce qu'il
ya du des liens de confiance avec une
administration locale avec des
personnels de santé connu des médecins
du secteur des infirmiers du secteur
c'est peut-être pas le cas pour les
grands axes cynodrome et je pense que
c'est pas bien qu'une réflexion qu'on
peut avoir
peut-être faut-il revenir à une certaine
proximité à régénérer ce lien de
confiance qu'on avait dans les centres
de proximité qui n'existe peut pas être
pas dans ces grands excès monde mais
encore une fois en israël on a trouvé le
mode reçoit un texto et même si on a 30
ans 40 ans c'est pas grave c'est la fin
de la journée ils n'osent on se présente
on se fait vacciner
il faut être efficace voilà et je pense
que les français sont demandeurs
d'efficacité alexandre douzynoise juste
quelques secondes en un mot il y a eu
une autre annonce un concernant le pass
sanitaires un temps écartée il était
jugé trop à maturer le passeport
vaccinale est désormais dans les tuyaux
un du gouvernement c'est qu'au niveau
européen est bien certain pour certains
pays sa grâce un petit peu pour vous est
ce qu'il est devenu un indispensable
aujourd'hui se passe sanitaires ont fait
on va dire que de nombreux pays vont le
mettre en place des nombreuses
compagnies est réel et de transport
ce qui n'est pas acceptable à mon avis
elle
est en place un an que chaque français
et chaque français
et puis se faire vacciner parce que ça
ça serait un bon avis inacceptable il y
aurait une sous-catégorie jacques dire
deux françaises qui seraient pas
admissibles
mais une fois que l'opportunité de se
vacciner alors été offert à chacun le
fait qu'on puisse redémarrer l'économie
c'est à dire à des gens qui sont rexie
débat vous pouvez aller au restaurant
vous pouvez aller au cinéma etc et ça en
sécurité et de sorte de redémarrer plus
vite la vie économique et sociale oui je
suis plutôt d'accord voilà si ça nous
permet de faire redémarrer la machine et
puis de redonner un peu d'espoir aux
données la perspective aussi à nos
compatriotes qui vivent comme un long
tunnel d'enfermement je pense que c'est
quelque chose qui est positif merci à
vous alexandre bouzaid avoir accepté nos
travers six amour elle aujourd'hui dans
la matinale de rtl frange leur appel
président délégué les républicains la
prévention de la délinquance à la
sécurité du conseil départemental de
l'essonne